who needs TV when there's a brilliant
meteor shower happening right outside
meteor showers are nature's nocturnal
entertainment and they've been around a
lot longer than your favorite sitcom but
what are they exactly we sometimes refer
to them as shooting stars or falling
stars but that's a far cry from reality
in truth when we see a meteor shower
we're witnessing the fiery demise of
tiny thousand-year-old comet fragments
as they collide with our planet without
comments we wouldn't have most of the
spectacular meteor showers that take
place each year like the stunning
Perseids in August and the breathtaking
Geminids in December
that's because comets are relatively
small and therefore have a weak
gravitational pull so loose particles of
dust and dirt on their surfaces only
need a gentle push and they'll go
tumbling off the comet and into space
that push comes from sunlight as comics
orbit the Sun the pressure from its
light is enough to nudge these particles
loose into the empty vacuum of outer
space once liberated the comet fragments
trace out a tail of dust extending for
millions of miles and they can remain
there for thousands of years
sometimes earth collides with these
Comet dust tails and when that happens
bits of the tiny fragments get swept up
by Earth's gravity and just like
Newton's apple they begin to fall toward
Earth flying through our atmosphere at
blazing speeds of over 100,000 miles an
hour but don't worry most of these
particles are no larger than a grain of
sand and so they burn up into nothing
before they hit the ground
now each meteor shower will usually last
over the course of a couple of weeks but
there's always a peak time to see them
that's when Earth is traveling through
the densest part of the cloud and when
the most dust particles are hurling
themselves through our atmosphere during
some of the best showers we can see over
100 meteors an hour so the next time
there's a major meteor shower turn off
the TV
go outside and look up that's all it
takes to witness cosmic beauty in action
you